how bad is the completely unrestricted
model
so how much do you understand about that
you know the there's uh there's been a
lot of discussion about Free Speech
absolutism yeah how much uh if that's
applied to an AI system you know we've
talked about putting out the base models
at least for researchers or something
but it's not very easy to use everyone's
like give me the base model and again we
might we might do that I think what
people mostly want is they want a model
that has been rlh deft
to the world view they subscribe to it's
really about regulating other people's
speech yeah like people just like
implied you know and like in the debates
about what showed up in the Facebook
feed I I having listened to a lot of
people talk about that everyone is like
well it doesn't matter what's in my feed
because I won't be radicalized I can
handle anything but I really worry about
what Facebook shows you
I would love it if there's some way
which I think my interaction with GPT
has already done that some way to in a
nuanced way present the tension of ideas
I think we are doing better at that than
people realize the challenge of course
when you're evaluating this stuff is uh
you can always find anecdotal evidence
of GPT slipping up and saying something
either wrong or um biased and so on but
it would be nice to be able to kind of
generally make statements about the bias
of the system generally make statements
about there are people doing good work
there you know if you ask the same
question 10 000 times yeah and you rank
the outputs from best to worse
what most people see is of course
something around output 5000 but the
output that gets
all of the Twitter attention is output
ten thousand yeah and this is something
that I think the world will just have to
adapt to with these models is that you
know sometimes there's a really
egregiously dumb answer
and in a world where you click
screenshot and share
that might not be representative now
already we're noticing a lot more people
respond to those things saying well I
tried it and got this and so I think we
are building up the antibodies there but
it's a new thing
do you feel
pressure
from clickbait journalism that looks at
ten thousand
that looks at the worst possible output
of GPT
do you feel a pressure to not be
transparent because of that no because
you're sort of making mistakes in public
and you burned for the mistakes
is there a pressure culturally within
open AI that you're afraid you like it
might close you up I mean evidently
there doesn't seem to be we keep doing
our thing you know so you don't feel
that I mean there is a pressure but it
doesn't affect you
I'm sure it has all sorts of subtle
effects I don't fully understand
but I don't perceive much of that I mean
we're happy to admit when we're wrong we
want to get better and better
um
I think we're pretty good about
trying to listen to every piece of
criticism
think it through internalize what we
agree with but like the breathless click
bait headlines
you know I try to let those flow through
us
uh what is the open AI moderation
tooling for GPT look like what's the
process of moderation so there's uh
several things maybe maybe it's the same
thing you can educate me so rlhf is the
ranking
but is there a wall you're up against
like
uh where this is an unsafe thing to
answer
what does that tooling look like we do
have systems that try to figure out you
know try to learn when a question is
something that we're supposed to we call
it refusals refuse to answer
it is early and imperfect uh were again
the spirit of building in public and
and bring Society along gradually we put
something out it's got flaws we'll make
better versions
um but yes we are trying the system is
trying to learn questions that it
shouldn't answer one small thing that
really bothers me about our current
thing and we'll get this better is
I don't like the feeling of being
scolded by a computer
yeah
I really don't you know I a story that
has always stuck with me I don't know if
it's true I hope it is is that the
reason Steve Jobs put that handle on the
back of the first iMac remember that big
plastic bright colored thing was that
you should never trust a computer you
shouldn't throw out you couldn't throw
out a window
nice and of course not that many people
actually throw their computer out a
window but it's sort of nice to know
that you can
and it's nice to know that like this is
a tool very much in my control and this
is a tool that like does things to help
me and I think we've done a pretty good
job of that with gpt4 but
I noticed that I have like a visceral
response to being scolded by a computer
and I think you know that's a good
learning from the point or from creating
a system and we can improve it it's
Yeah It's Tricky and also for the system
not to treat you like a child treating
our users like adults is a thing I say
very frequently inside inside the office
but It's Tricky it has to do with
language like
if there's like certain conspiracy
theories you don't want the system to be
speaking to
it's a very tricky language you should
use because what if I want to understand
the Earth if the Earth is the idea that
the Earth is flat and I want to fully
explore that
I want the I want gpg to help me explore
gbt4 has enough Nuance to be able to
help you explore that without
and treat you like an adult in the
process gbg3 I think just wasn't capable
of getting that right but gbt4 I think
we can get to do this by the way if you
could just speak to the leap from uh
gpt4 to gpt4 from 3.5 from three is
there some technical leaps or is it
really focused on the alignment no it's
a lot of technical leaps in the base
model one of the things we are good at
at open AI is finding a lot of small
wins and multiplying them together
and each of them maybe is like a pretty
big secret in some sense but it really
is the multiplicative
impact of all of them
and the detail and care we put into it
that gets us these big leaps and then
you know it looks like to the outside
like oh they just probably like did one
thing to get from three to three point
five to four
it's like hundreds of complicated things
it's a tiny little thing with the
training with the like everything with
the data organization how we like
collect the data how we clean the data
how we do the training how we do the
optimizer how we do the architect like
so many things